Wow it's been having dreams about being
a speedster memories of that life it's
okay to be scared why I am all Wally
wants to do is help people
now you're getting powers the time let's
calm using my head wally was suggest
loud it's all because I created
flashpoint
you have no idea what's about to begin
the flash all new Tuesday November Mandi
hey youtubers it's Charlie new flash
trailer teasing some dark flash and some
sabotage so I'll explain daniel west and
walter west from the comics so here we
go whole bunch of stuff happening in
this trailer seems like wall-e is going
to be getting his powers via dr. alchemy
like he even gets into what looks like a
fistfight with iris because he starts to
go crazy they have to contain him she's
probably trying to keep him from seeking
dr. alchemy out for his own good like he
just can't handle it anymore so he just
completely drinks the kool-aid we get a
better look at dr. Alchemy's lair the
Philosopher's Stone and we see like a
little light effect streaking across the
frame that looks like it might be Sava
tar it's like the same thing when we saw
the rival die so we might be getting the
first taste of sabotage Grant Gustin was
teasing recently that yo you won't have
to wait long to see him at all so
because we really didn't see anything
from him in episode 5 that that makes me
think that we're going to get a teaser
in episode 6 and then we'll start
learning a little bit more about him
like dr. alchemy teases that something
really big is getting ready to start so
I think that's the onset of Savitt are
like when things really start to get
crazy the title of the episode is called
shade now that has a lot of different
meanings but mostly I think they're
talking about
Wally's shadow that you know the shadow
of him from that other timeline that was
the flash so as with all things like you
make a deal with the devil things get
really dark so the offhanded name drop
of Walter West in episode 5 makes a
little bit more sense now so Walter West
was a version of Wally West from a
different timeline who basically
experienced this crazy tragedy that
normal Wally West did not and even
though it didn't drive him mad
completely it did turn him into this
hardcore person out for justice at any
cost
kind of like a version of The Punisher
if the Punisher had the powers of the
flash so there was this arc in the
comics called the dark flash with all
the normal flash characters so even
though I don't think the TV show is
going to do like an evil version of
Wally I'll explain
Daniel West in a second too because that
is
an iris west brother evil reverse-flash
character but I do think they're going
to be a lot of Easter eggs from Marc
Wade's dark flash run we're deep in Mark
Waid territory Mark Waid did sabotage
run and he did the dark flash Walter
West run so if you're big fan of Mark
Waid this is definitely your time on the
flash but the TV show you know tends to
spin things in a slightly more hopeful
way but if you feel like you know when
they're doing the like iris berry
relationshipy stuff it gets like a
little too sweet that's usually when
they pull the rug out from under the
characters so just when things seem like
they've calmed down that's really when
they're gonna crank it up and get crazy
so that's why I think they're dropping a
slightly darker version of wall-e
via dr. alchemy and savat are really
soon but obviously it's meant to be a
more wall-e heavy episode but we're
going to learn a whole bunch more about
dr. alchemy on the TV show so just be
listening for clues and be on the
lookout for Savitt R even if he doesn't
slow down like even if he just white
streaks across the frame but daniel west
a lot of you are probably familiar with
the daniel west reverse-flash
he was irises brother like they
basically changed the new 52 iris West
family so instead of wally west being
her brother his name was Daniel West he
had this really troubled past he'd been
through the prison system but then got
the Speed Force in this accident in you
know because of his troubled past
decided to use his powers to try and
undo the terrible things that had
happened to him so in that version of
events Barry you know basically had to
stop him from completely unraveling all
their lives and save him because he
always had like this Darth Vader moment
where there's like an evil seeming
character that might have some good in
them so you try to kind of bring that
out so that was kind of like the Daniel
West flash arc but he became the
reverse-flash of the new 52 because
eobard thawne wasn't around so later he
actually became part of the Suicide
Squad they tried to use him in
interesting ways but then they did
rebirth so they've kind of wiped the
slate clean from all that stuff so we
brought back the pre-crisis wally west
and this other new 52 version of wally
west who's now like a much younger
version of the flash like you know you
can see they're doing this flash of two
worlds you know funny cover here
but just to be clear the TV show is
doing like a you know a slight
combination of all these different
things so it's not going to be like a
carbon copy of the comic book plot but
if you want to read up the dark flash
saga starting I think it starts with
flash number 151 side note volume 1
number 151 was a story involving the
shade as the villain invaders from the
Dark Dimension the title of the episode
is the shade so there might be Easter
eggs for that too so you can go back and
read Silver Age flash and then read
volume 2 with Wally West in number 151
for that dark flash run and then if you
haven't already and you really want to
read more on Sabbat are just read the
Savitt are run from Mark Waid that
starts with issue 108 so sabot R
happened in the comics way before like
the dark flash Walter West saga but if
you think the flash has been like
spinning its wheels like the last week
or two like this is where it really
starts to get crazy they're building to
the mid-season finale we have like the
four night crossover which will be like
a whole bunch of other crazy Dominator
stuff so just a reminder that next week
the flash is on break just because it's
an election week in the United States
like the whole election once that's over
everything goes back to normal so the
next episode of the flash isn't for two
weeks but I'll do like a flash bonus
video next week anyway so no worries the
other really big news I know but you're
asking about that this morning they
announced that Talia al Ghul is coming
on to arrow they didn't say when she's
gonna appear or how she's gonna appear
or what storyline they're doing just
that they're doing Talia what I think
they'll probably use her for is to
eventually reform the League of
Assassins
and I think you know partly would help
them make the decision to bring her on
is that the actress who plays Nyssa al
Ghul is on another TV show so I think
they wanted to do League of Assassins
stuff and they needed a character so
they're like okay why don't we just go
ahead and do Talia so it'll all make
sense once she shows up and they'll
probably start teasing her pretty soon
too but there is new arrow tonight I'll
do a video for it but there's like four
or five videos that I need to get out so
I'll try to figure out what the order is
going to be there's a ghostwriter video
like Johnny Blaze came on agents of
shield so I'm going to try and get that
video out next so hopefully by the
I might post that video I'll have a
better idea what the video schedule is
going to be so we'll be posting updates
through the rest of the day
no worries and there is a DC giveaway
that's going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card so ghostrider
posting in a little while what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my episode 5 Easter Egg video and
you can click here to learn all about
the drama that's going on with the flash
movie they just lost their director so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight